plus de goût
[Musique]
dans un quartier industriel une banque
alimentaire alors on est plus à
l'intérieur de l'entrepôt un mois son
aval puis c'est la section ici un
comptoir alimentaire d'urgence
ça ressemble à une petite épicerie de
laisser le but c'est ce que je voulais
créer un peu depuis que je suis ici je
voulais que les gens sentent à l'aise je
voulais faire un méchant aux petites
épiceries sympathie au québec depuis le
début de la pandémie
plus de 650 mille personnes ont demandé
de l'aide alimentaire
la crise n'étant pas terminée un
québécois sur cinq croit qu'il aura
besoin d' aide pour se nourrir ni psy
d'urgence en fait si lorsque les gens
sont vraiment l'eau à cours de
nourriture soit qu'ils ont plus accès à
la nourriture sans arrêt capacité
d'aller la chercher son taux bâle ii ya
plus rien à l'art moi les gens ils
partent avec une bonne épicerie soin de
valada peu près 300 $ et plus
notre particularité faire en sorte que
nous non seulement on distribue les
aliments et les denrées aux organismes
mais également aux individus si jamais
les gens le savent pas vers qui se
tourner ou vers où se tourner il faut
pas hésiter à nous appeler parce que on
peut donner une aide d'urgence
on peut se sentir déboussolé lorsqu'on
vit une telle situation et ne pas savoir
vers quel service se tourner si on n'a
pas accès directement on connaît pas moi
son canapé sans le bénévolat mois son
lover
on sait pas où il est situé personne
n'en parlait a soif alors à présent le 2
à 1 ce service gratuit téléphonique qui
offre toutes les possibilités d'accéder
à toutes les ressources avait beaucoup
personnes qui soudainement se sont
questionnés sur kim équipe
brigitte gagnon boudreau et la
directrice du service de 1,1 un centre
de référence dont la mission est
d'informer pour aider vraiment pour
connaître les organismes qui existe dans
le revo comme nos pères qui peuvent
venir en aide aux personnes selon leurs
besoins
donc c'est plus de 5000 organisme qui
existe dans notre base de données
normalement les demandes aide
alimentaire ça concerne environ 10% de
notamment puis au pic de la crise au
début d'avril ont constaté que ces 60%
pensent qu'une grande inquiétude les
gens ont vraiment voulu s'assurer
d'avoir accès à des aliments
le service offert dans la majorité des
grandes villes canadiennes est aussi
accessible en ligne
on évalue votre situation chaque
organisme à ces exigences et l'aide
alimentaire de prendre plusieurs formes
et les banques alimentaires un peu plus
classique comme on les connaît mais il
ya aussi des concepts se sont
développées d'épicerie économique de
magasins partage
enfin les articles sur place vont coûter
10 % le ch'ti coûte normalement en
épicerie donc c'est vraiment plus
accessible par exemple une brique de
fromage coûte normalement 10 dollars ils
vont la payer seulement indolore qui en
a qui distribue des coupons nourriture
en fait c'est des bons d'achat dans
l'épicerie donc les personnes m'ont pour
aller directement est le même à
l'épicerie avec ce bond à chaleur
s'ajoutent les cuisines collectives les
repas préparés les repas économique
il ya donc plusieurs types d' aide
alimentaire il y à aussi comment faire
des économies dans ce parc au coeur de
la ville nous rencontrons cynthia cunéo
de sos cuisine est ce que c'est possible
en temps de pandémie de faire réellement
des économies à l'épicerie on a
l'impression que la facture d'épicerie
ne fait qu'augmenter
oui c'est toujours possible et les
règles sont toujours les règles qui sont
volés dans tout en pandémie ou pas
pandémie la première chose est planifiée
il faut absolument qu'on sache de quoi
on a besoin au regard de son frigo garde
manger on regarde les spéciaux et on se
dresse une liste comme ça quand on
arrive à l'épicerie
on est préparé on va pas avoir d' achat
impulsif
on ne va pas faire de gaspillage
cependant les aliments coûte cher et on
peut penser qu actuellement il y a moins
de rabais en épicerie il y en a beaucoup
moins 50% moins sur les produits
transformés donc les produits de
boulangerie les céréales du matin les
biscuits tout ça il y en a moins
mais heureusement fort heureusement là
où il s'agit de viande poisson fruits
légumes produits frais il ya toujours
beaucoup de spéciaux et des bons
spéciaux si on surveille bien des
spéciaux de circulaire on peut
effectivement deux personnes sauf
facilement 100 dollars par mois
mais difficile de savoir si l'aliment
est à bon prix
il ya différents outils comme par
exemple l'évaluateur de prix de sos
cuisine en évaluateurs de prix c'est
gratuit il sachant quel est le prix les
gens peuvent entrer et voir si ça vaut
la peine ou ça vaut pas la peine en ce
moment toutes les semaines on compare
les prix sur base régulière et homogène
et on peut arriver à qualifier les prix
donc on a un système qui a 2 po ce ça
veut dire que c'est très avantageux
on dit pas vraiment un bon prix parce
qu'il ya aussi ça pour nous attirer en
magasin il ya des fois des produits qui
ne sont pas tellement intéressant
acheter
consultez les sites internet des
circulaires en ligne peut aussi nous
aider
tout comme certaines applications selon
madame kuni ou alors effectivement il ya
des outils sur internet haut débit par
exemple qu'on peut avoir accès aux
spéciaux de tous les magasins il y en a
pas besoin de découvrir ça une fois
rendu dans le magasin on peut le faire
avance puis aussi des applications
maintenant pour utiliser des produits
qui sont comme en fin de vie et donc fou
du roi il y en a d'autres qui vous
permet cetin mende ne pas gaspiller ses
applications anti-gaspillage permettent
de faire des économies
on y trouve des rabais sur les aliments
allant jusqu'à 60% du prix madame tuner
au suggère aussi de cuisine et selon les
spéciaux de choisir des coupes de vianne
économique et augmenter les portions
avec des légumineuses lentilles pois
chiches ou te flux sont moins chers pour
les fruits et les légumes suivre les
saisons planifié sert pas toujours on
revient à la base les produits frais
possiblement d'origine végétale avoir
une assiette comme le guide alimentaire
nous dit de faire avec les bonnes
proportions de fruits légumes produits
d'origine végétale
[Musique]
des trucs c'est planifié planifié
planifier et donc c'est toujours ça
c'est cuisine et cuisiner cuisine et je
pense que c'est difficile d'assumer ça
peut nous arriver à nous ici là je pense
qu'on a tous tendance un peu à a
considéré que ça arrive juste aux autres
ce genre de situation l'oeuvre qui a
plein de personnes qui nous demandent de
l'aide à chaque jour qui on est vraiment
là pour ça pour les bd puis les
organismes ou s'ils sont là pour ça
[Musique]